hey you guys today on the movie
retrospective we are entering a world of
pure imagination yeah talking about
what's probably one of my favorite
movies growing up and one that I you
know I have no compunctions about
watching over and over again this is the
original 1971 Willy Wonka & the
Chocolate effect one of Gene Wilder's
great roles goddamnit he was so [ __ ]
good yes
even though watching the movie again
there's not a lot of content in the
movie kind of good well getting to the
factory isn't like a big part of the
movie there I didn't realize there was
so much so much the movie was trying to
get was build-up was build-up but that's
what I kind of liked about it and I will
talk a little bit about the Tim Burton
one because okay here's the deal
zomb oh yeah um interestingly this
actually wasn't the movie that I had
scheduled for this week but I was
scrolling through Netflix and I was like
you know looking for someone I was like
man I just want something kind of fun to
watch that I can just kind of drink and
not have to really pay attention to it
or anything like that and I saw I was
like oh they they have the original
Willy Wonka it's like I love that
[ __ ] movie yeah so it's like we
decided to watch it and like I was kind
of you know inebriated so I was just
sitting there going I was like Tom we
should review this cuz I love this it's
like I've seen it like a million times
yeah yeah it's like you know it came out
that year before I was born and so I
mean ever since I was old enough to like
watch movies we've been seeing this
movie cuz like you know my parents ran a
daycare we had it like on Betamax and
then we had it on VHS and [ __ ] like that
so I've seen it I probably have it
memorized I think I've seen it on old
CRT TV and VHS you think you've seen the
movie you need to see it in HD it really
looks nice looks a lot like wow comment
on new TVs and you know in the new
digital media it looks a lot better it's
it seems like it took them a really long
time to like put out a nice like blu-ray
of it I think in 2011 they did like a
big like 40th anniversary like special
edition like that's completely restored
and it's like widescreen and you know it
came with the book and all this other
kind of stuff and like a wocket in
there's like a chocolate bar that time I
never
saw the theater but this is the way it
would have looked at a theater it looked
good yeah yeah so let's talk a little
bit about now obviously most people know
because this is kind of like you know
even though it's quote/unquote a kids
movie it has become like a massive cult
classic there's like [ __ ] Ghazi gene
Wilder memes it's like they're so like
everybody yeah like everybody knows this
movie even if they've never seen the
original one you know shots from it you
know the character names you know the
songs you know and everything like that
so I feel like it's really kind of
infiltrated into pop culture even though
it didn't do it didn't do badly at the
theater when it first came out but it
didn't do that great I think it was like
the Wikipedia said it was the 53rd
highest grossing movie of that year I
don't think it really became popular
until it hit television yeah constantly
on rotation and you know I think
wouldn't wonder what year this come out
68 71 71 oh yeah so I was too and at
first debuted on TV in 1975 okay and
then it kind of got showed a lot on you
know on TV like you know cuz I think I
saw it on just like regular network TV
when I was growing up and then later on
when it came out on VHS I think it's
kind of like steamrolled you know it
took a while to like find its footing
yeah I bet come on back you know when
there were only like ten channels 13
channels on YouTube well for a while we
had three and then when we had well a
technically four because we had PBS but
then when they added like Fox 35 yeah
that was like a big deal and I was like
I don't even remember yeah there were 13
79 earlier 13 channels originally aren't
you on television yeah most of them
didn't have channels on them so there
was like seven probably yeah actual
channels but yeah when you had the
little cog in the dial and that you know
and during that era you know what
showing Willy walk it was like an event
when you were a kid every other kid in
their neighborhood would watch it
oh man it's coming on yeah yeah yeah and
I really really only kind of remember
this movie from maybe around 77 78
that's around the time I kind yeah ember
it I think that's probably like I said I
probably saw it in 75 or 76 when I was
you know and I were five years old yeah
huge crush is on the
girls they were so especially Veruca
she's adorable and thought that girls
it's a horrible brat but she's really
good at and I had a huge crush on it
yes she's super cute yeah and they'll
the brattiness and [ __ ] you know yeah
you were like I thought I was hot yeah
well because she knew what she wanted
yeah she was very vocal about I was
letting people know I was into powerful
women but yeah so as most people know
this was based on the 1964 children's
book by Roald Dahl Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory now I think that I'm
not sure how much of a misconception
this is but it's like it is true that
Roald Dahl ended up not being completely
happy with how the you know how the film
came out although when they first
started um you know talking about making
this movie he was actually brought on as
a screenwriter so he actually wrote the
first iteration of the screenplay
and it was intended to be a musical from
the beginning it wasn't so much that
like you know later on they came and
said I was gonna be a misery music
musical and he was just like I'll [ __ ]
that and I'm not into it um he was kind
of just mad when they brought in like
another screenwriter I think it was
David Wolper - kind of like punch it up
they did change a few things from the
book but not I mean I read the book but
it was a long time ago i read that and i
read charlie in the great glass elevator
but i feel like some of the complaints
that he made about the changes were i
don't know i don't want to say misguided
necessarily because i can see where he's
coming from but it's ironic to me that
one of the main complaints he made when
the film came out was that one he didn't
like that the movie title had been
changed to Willy Wonka and the Chocolate
Factory which they actually did because
I don't know if most people know but
this movie was almost entirely funded by
the Quaker Oats Company they were they
gave three million dollars which is
about how much it costs to make it and
because they were launching a new line
of candy bars and they wanted to kind of
get in
film business like his future like
advertising I guess it ended up like
that the Wonka bars that they put out
were not hugely successful although they
think the Wonka candy company is still
around but they actually named it after
the character because of this movie so
this is basically a feature-length
Quaker Oats commercial just product
placement even though I don't think I
mean I don't think people realize that
nowadays but yeah quicker it's put up
pretty much the whole Lanka well know
what ended up happening was that Mel
Stewart the guy that directed this his
daughter read the book and was like
Daddy we need to make a movie out of
this so he knew like a producer and then
he got Quaker Oats to buy the rights to
the book okay and then fun to the movie
because they said oh well because he was
talking to Quaker Oats at the moment
because they were like we want to go to
the film business because we're
launching a new candy line of blah blah
blah so it was kind of like kismet like
it all kind of came together I do
remember a candy line called walk there
was yeah but it didn't have any do it
quick roads um no they did own it
oh I asked you yeah he said no oh I
thought you meant that did they own
something else yeah they did own that
they don't that makes exam remember as a
kid the candy even kind of had a similar
font yeah
well that's why yeah yeah because it all
tied together it was okay yeah it was
okay like I said I don't know if it's
still around and I'm if it is still
around I don't know Quaker Oats still
owns it although quicker it's kind of
quicker owns kind of a lot of [ __ ] okay
um but yeah so they said they changed it
to Willy Wonka in the chocolate factory
so it would tie in with the candy line
better
he also Roald Dahl also thought and like
I said this to me is very ironic in
light of the later adapted he thought
that the focus was too much on Willy
Wonka and not on Charlie who is the main
character of the book which is very
funny to me because the movie the
original if you see it pretty much the
whole first half of the movie is about
Charlie I mean yeah it's about like the
other kids that find the golden tickets
and stuff but I mean the focus is mainly
on Charlie you know his mom sings a song
to him it's like kind of him and his
grandfather and stuff like that and him
kind of you know wanting to win the
ticket and you know his whole thing
about it but when Tim Burton made the
[ __ ] in
2004/2005 whenever it was that movie was
almost entirely about Willy Wonka and
yet it was called Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory like the kids and that
one we're almost like an afterthought
like especially once they got to the
factory and started walking around it
seemed like it was all on Johnny Depp's
like eccentric performance let's call it
that I kind of hated it yeah that movie
was I kind of made it as a problem there
that could have been a great movie yeah
they just made some some wrong calls I
mean I loved Tim Burton I loved Johnny
Depp but this that movie was really a
misfire Tim Burton can get awful Tim
Burton II sometimes yeah but actually
kind of kept it too it kept it low I
think in in Charlie the chocolate fest
yeah actually you know uh what's his
name [ __ ] man trying to play cuz I'm
just waking up it's fairly early we have
yet
giant Depp's a great actor look he
looked [ __ ] fantastic in the movie it
was like yeah he said he's got it's
copped out and everything he's in the
[ __ ] cool outfit was like walk it
would look like that
but his choice of how to do that
character I just didn't agree with it
whoo yeah crossed a little bit Michael
Jackson II you know yeah cross is like
creepy he should have been more like
sweetie Todd but funny Lykos yeah person
asleep because there is no threat yeah
in that character and if you go back and
look at Gene Wilder gene waters a little
bit threatening that was an obit was the
best thing about Gene Wilder and Gene
Wilder was actually not the first choice
like actually a lot of people wanted
this role like all the members of Monty
Python wanted it all this other stuff so
Roald Dahl actually wanted Spike
Milligan but he didn't want to do it so
when they got Gene Wilder apparently
like a bunch of other people had tried
out for the role but as soon as Gene
Wilder walked in they're like that's him
that's who we want so gene Wilder said
he would take and in fact after he left
the audition I guess the producer the
casting director chased him down the
hall and said would you please do it
it's like you're Willy Wonka Gene Wilder
said he would only do it if he could
introduce the character with that very
iconic thing where he comes out of the
factory like with the cane and he's
limping and it takes a really long time
and everyone in the crowd goes quiet and
then like he the the cane gets stuck in
the cobblestones and he keeps going then
he falls forward and then he totals he
said I wanted to do that because I
wanted to establish from the outset that
you didn't know when this character was
lying or when he was telling the tree
yeah and that's the right call cuz I
remember that as a kid seeing that for
the first time what an impression that
made us whoa
because it wasn't what you're expecting
yeah and and what I liked about this
movie is that this Chocolate Factory and
Willy we're scary there was a certain
scary element to them it was a mixture
of scary and funny
yeah and Wonder and kind of horror
slightly yeah but in the end it all
worked out you know you he was a good
guy it but there's there that mix of
emotion is very effective on kids oh
yeah and that if it's too [ __ ] funny
you just ignore it if it's too scary you
you you you block it out that weird
mixture like the old rides at Disneyland
yeah like the old snow white it had
[ __ ] scary [ __ ] in it I love that
ride yeah the enemy because the kids
like to be scared oh yeah they like a
good mixture of that kind of stuff that
was it like I said I think they really
hit the perfect tone in the original
movie because Gene Wilder he comes
across as kind of avuncular like he's a
like he's a kindly person but he also
comes across as eccentric maybe he's a
little mean maybe he's a little
mysterious um you never know like and
maybe a little deranged you're not quite
sure and it's like like I said he seems
really unpredictable yeah and I think
that that really kind of like informs
the character because you never know
exactly how it's gonna go like now but
it was like a emotional rollercoaster is
yeah you're going to the damn factory
and there's this Wonderland this big
room of candy it looks like a park man
at a candy and the little fat kid gets
[ __ ] sucked up in the damn I almost
thought he dies yeah yeah no and you're
like oh what the hell and then they get
on that goddamn bow alright get up in
the centipede
yeah cutting the chicken's head off and
and then like Willy Wonka's you know I
don't remember the [ __ ] rhyme because
that [ __ ] spooky ass ride by which
way we're wrong with yes sanity and that
emotional rollercoaster of going up and
down and up and down I mean that's kids
don't forget it
that's what I mean I'm not maybe like
bond in with that movie like wow that
was exciting
yeah that I made a huge impression if it
didn't have those scary parts in there
you'd have forgotten about that movie
yeah which i think is what's gonna
happen to the remake yeah I guess I
don't want to call it a remake is it's
just another adaptation of the novel one
thing I will get the Tim Burton one is
it is a lot more faithful to the book it
looks a lot better
it looks cool like you get like a more
of a sense begin of you know because
even got good songs in it
although there's not as good as the old
songs are fun but they're not very
memorable yeah the only one I remember
is that really one guy Willy Wonka and
that's just because it's annoying as
[ __ ] yeah yeah the first one was pretty
good yeah but you know about the kid who
got sucked up in the pipe that was it
that was a good one what they were all
pretty good it's just that they didn't
think they didn't have they didn't have
a same theme that kind of went through
yeah the original songs did kind of have
a same theme yes sound well I mean the
oopall Oompa songs that's one thing I
didn't like I kind of in theory I liked
the idea in Tim Burton's adaptation that
it's like every subsequent oopah Loompa
song was like from a different decade
like one of them kind of sounded like a
funky disco thing and one sounded like
you know what I mean in 170 rock yeah it
kind of sounded like that one 7th sended
like like 70s folk or something like
that but the problem is that one that
the songs were super memorable and
- the whole point of the IMP Olympus
songs was to like chastise the children
and even though they took a lot of the
lyrics in the Tim Burton version from
Roald Dahl's original book a lot of
times I couldn't understand what they
were saying you know what I mean because
like there was too much that it was very
the music was very over produced and it
was like a big number and stuff so I
couldn't tell what the lyrics were a lot
of the times because you know my hearing
is kind of shooting anyway so I I kind
of like in the original version the
Oompa Loompa songs which all had the
same tune but then they would change the
words up depending on the kid and
depending on what they're yeah the
original story it wasn't all this body
positivity and all this PC [ __ ] now that
was that the straight up the movie was
like you [ __ ] suck because you're fat
all right
I suck because you chew [ __ ] gum yeah
you suck because you [ __ ] you're
violent and that was the theme of this
movie you don't I mean and it was
effective it definitely was yeah um I I
feel like and then it came around and
says it was your parents that are the
reason yeah your parents [ __ ] you up
their parents and you [ __ ] these kind
of messages or what kids have to hear
[Laughter]
sup it's like a Grimm fairy tales
yeah well and the cool thing about it
too is that in the original and yes
there's a line in the original like near
the end because when Charlie asks Willy
Wonka it's like what happened to the
other kids he says oh you know they're
fine or whatever but they don't show
them like in the book he says they're
fine and they leave the factory in Tim
Burton's version Charlie sees them from
that glass elevator like leaving the
factory but I think it was better in the
1911 to not show them leaving because
you could think maybe Willy Wonka's
lying maybe maybe he killed them I
assumed that I I said that your dad I
assume it is ended the [ __ ] was not
reversed that yeah she looked like a
goddamn bully beriberi yeah and that
[ __ ] what's-his-name got [ __ ]
stretched and bites and that [ __ ] the
German kid was just [ __ ] fat stuck in
damn pipes any
and deferred she never got about yeah I
guess it's better to [ __ ] to think
that no way better somebody better to
think that they were destroyed yeah
that's what I think they had to pay for
your sins yeah everything that's way
life is you get [ __ ] up [ __ ] if you do
the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you could die yeah
that's the way really is you know that's
I had to be told that as a little kid
because I was inclined to do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you were like jump off the top of
[ __ ] roof of the house a damn model
airplane in my hands trying to flip flap
my wings and [ __ ] album covers plane
would do you know stealing [ __ ]
gasoline out lawnmower trying to set
[ __ ] on fire you know yeah I was I was a
real boy yeah it destroyed everything
but yeah it's like burn down any houses
well finish it off our set the woods on
fire my brother did tale yeah we put it
out but it was close yeah my brother's
did that real [ __ ] close but they you
know putting off like I don't know where
she BB guns
yeah put on a motorcycle how much each
other the BB guns we're bulletproof or a
blow gun yeah Adam whoa gun with [ __ ]
darts in it yeah so these movies were
effective because they remind you from
an early age there are limits yeah
because the great thing about this is
that yes it's a kids movie it's a
fantasy but it has like it's grounded in
realism
it's scary um it's kind of like I mean
even from the very beginning one of my
favorite scenes and when we were
rewatching it cuz I've seen this a
million times but one of my favorite
scenes I have to say and you know this
is one thing I really like more than you
know the reboot or the Tim Burton
version is because this retains a lot
more mystery like there's a scene in it
where Charlie Bucket
is in front of the closed gates of
Wonka's factory and this dude like with
a cart with all these knives and
cleavers and [ __ ] hanging off it he
comes in like starts reciting that poem
it's called the fairies actually yeah
about you no no and then he says nobody
ever goes in and no
yeah and I was scaring the movie
actually yeah and it's like that it just
established such a tone and it really
like got me into because I loved scary
[ __ ] as a kid and especially anything
that was like a kids movie but also had
scary [ __ ] in it like I was all into
like the secret of NIMH and watership
down and all that kind of stuff gave the
movie wait yeah a kid yeah oh this stuff
matters yeah that things could happen
yeah and I think a lot of I think a lot
of the some of these newer jintan some
of the newer generation the kids you
know I mean they're their parents are
doping them up but at early age and then
they put them in a totally safe like and
controlled environment type of school
and I'm gonna let them play [ __ ]
dodgeball it's ridiculous because these
kids aren't living life in full color
and once they're out of school it comes
at them they can't handle it you know
man [ __ ] I've just been listening to
guys online talked about it you know
that they come out of school and go to
the [ __ ] first time they go to a
[ __ ] nightclub and putting to say
something screwy and they get [ __ ]
their block knocked off they didn't
realize that that could happen yeah yeah
I mean it's just yeah there are
repercussions yeah like you know like I
said I said if you learned that early
yeah so I that's why I always kind of
liked kids movies that had like a scary
element yeah so like I said I really
liked you know that there was this
mystery and they're like that they left
it mysterious you don't really know cuz
that was one thing that really pissed me
off about the Tim Burton version is that
yes it's more faithful to the book but
one he added like a whole bunch of
backstory like why Willy Wonka became
Willy Wonka's dad was a dentist and poor
Christopher Lee like was in this but yet
it's like who [ __ ] cares about that
they show him going to limp a land and
like getting them just like I don't
[ __ ] care about that it's just like
it's better to leave it it's like you go
in this [ __ ] factory you don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on you go in
there there's Oompa Loompas he said yeah
I got him from yet or whatever they
don't show it yeah actually the loophole
and scene in the remake demystified
that's what you mean that's dumb as
they're not show it don't do that keep
everything a mystery no I don't want to
know Willy why not Maggie that's what 15
years old maybe years old I think well
14 years I think it came
mm or 5i I think they tried to define it
I think I think Tim Burton was trying to
find a compromise between the old movie
and the book yeah but there were certain
things about the original movie that
were done right you know I mean in in
violation of the book because sometimes
just because you write the book doesn't
mean you know how to make the movie yeah
all right
the first movie was done right they
should have just did more of that yeah
and top that because I mean there were a
lot of changes made in the 1971 version
from the book I mean some of the changes
like the character of slugworth he was
actually mentioned in the book but he
wasn't like a big character he was
actually added by the second
screenwriter like because they thought
they need to like an antagonist even
that was a good idea and that was a good
idea also the whole morality test thing
where you know Charlie goes in at the
end and it really liked it yells at him
yeah and then he gives him back the
Everlasting Gobstopper like saying I
even made that even if you're mean to me
I'm not gonna [ __ ] you over
yeah that would that's what gave the
movie meaning right and it's like that
wasn't in the book either and in Tim
Burton's version when he which is more
faithful to the book basically the he
just gives Charlie the factory because
he was the only kid left that didn't do
anything bad and so that's another thing
too and this was also a problem with the
book and with the Tim Burton version is
that Charlie in those is like saintly
he's like not like a real kid he's
almost like a cipher like everything he
does is completely selfless and it's not
realistic in like the original one the
kid who played Charlie I think is name
is Peter Ostrom he was he was so [ __ ]
good in this in getting you to invest in
his care he seemed like a real kid he
was like a good kid a very good-hearted
kid a selfless kid but he did things
like kind of selfishly like a real kid
would yeah Charlie and is Charlie and
his uncle in the remake are basically
nonentities if you asked me they're not
that's like the kids were not in the
original movie what we're talking about
here they were [ __ ] definite
characters they actually yeah they drove
the story forward which that
a lot better I don't know I never read
it I never read the book but if it
wasn't like that in the book it should
have been yes I said just because you're
right the book doesn't necessarily mean
you know the story yeah there were other
guys who can come in there and go oh I
see what you're doing but you [ __ ]
this up why this and you can you know
Star Wars is like that I throw that out
a lot
Star Wars is like that you know Star
Wars can get to George Lucas II yeah and
then it's it's not cool anymore yeah you
know I mean and then it can go to Disney
and it's not cool anymore you know like
I can see how like I can see where Roald
Dahl was coming from and like I said
some things and we talked about this
when we talked about Stephen King
adaptations particularly it's like some
things that work very well on the page
don't work very well in a movie so I
feel like Roald Dahl I think was trying
to make the character of Charlie Bucket
kind of bland and also kind of saintly
so you could project yourself into it
like when you were reading it which I
can see that but when you're making it
into a movie you need a kid that you can
relate to that you can feel for yeah and
I just don't feel like they did that
like in the Tim Burton version that kid
was fine he was adorable looking he was
a good actor but he didn't seem like a
realistic kid yeah it's a lot of times
you know the best movies are almost kind
of a group effort there's one yeah it
comes up with the main idea and
everybody loves it and then they go yeah
yeah it's great but you know I need this
and it's got to have this and any of it
and this is how you make it in a movie
there's three or four guys talk and the
whole point the whole scene of like
Charlie and his grandpa stealing fizzy
lifting drinks that was not in the book
either but that was so good because that
showed not only that grandpa Joe would
like corrupt the kid if necessary but it
also kind of showed how I mean because
the kid was like excited this was like
his dream come true and it's like for a
second even though he knew it was wrong
he just got really excited yeah and his
grandpa was like come on let's do it
have a good time and [ __ ] like that and
he gave into it which a real kid would
do another thing that was kind of weird
about both movies I think the first
movie
I did a little bit of a better job at it
kind of other line the fact that
Charlie's family was most of Charlie's
family was parasitical Dave yeah that's
right they were just parasites they
stayed in bed all day and pretended to
be sick while the mom did all the work
yeah and Charlie did he was a paperboy
as soon as they got yeah and as soon as
soon as the golden ticket came up all of
a sudden
uncle [ __ ] jumps out of bed like iPod
your grandpa Joe jumps out of bed I know
I was like you [ __ ] gold breaker you
could cut up this whole time but laying
there for 20 years and then a remake
they showed it to he just jumped up oh
I'm okay yeah yeah which the theme of
the movie was is that kids are [ __ ] up
by their families so they could have
probably gone a little more depth about
getting the factory was a way of getting
away from your family they kind of did
it in the second movie because yeah oh
how bad families were yes because his
dad had [ __ ] him over but it kind of
cleaned that up too didn't know how
families are okay but I don't think that
was the original intent of the story
probably yeah these are families are
responsible for [ __ ] you up I'm not
really sure know what one thing I did
like that they did in the original movie
that was not from the book was that they
made Charlie's dad was gone he was
presumably dead or he had taken off or
something like that which in a way kind
of deepened his relationship with Willy
Wonka because it was like he was looking
for another father figure you know what
I mean
so um you know because his dad was alive
in the book and in the remake he worked
in a toothpaste Factory and then he got
laid off or something like that so so I
like that they just made his dad like
not in the original movie so it kind of
made their situation seem a little bit
more desperate and also like I said that
he was looking for a father figure and
you know another thing too is that the
coolest thing about I'm being Gene
Wilder I love [ __ ] Gene Wilder and
pretty much everything I mean Young
Frankenstein was one of my favorite
comedies ever but he's so good in this
because he's he's like I just love the
[ __ ] sarcasm like he seems
unconcerned about the kid
and I like Oh it'll be okay or whatever
but it's like just he's so like calm and
that you know like the kid falls in the
river and like his mom is flipping out
he's just like help police murder you
know what I mean it's just like I [ __ ]
loved that when I was a kid
yeah and that was kind of the problem
with the remake the Johnny Depp's
interpretation of is it was a little too
affected and you know yeah he doesn't
seem like a real person he seemed like a
caricature been better had he just
played that role very straight straight
and been a little bit more like Sweeney
Todd and then done some goofy stuff
every now and then it was funny every
now and then and kind of left him a
little more ambiguous yeah because what
made that character great or Wilders
interpretation of that character was he
was slightly sinister and he seemed like
a real person yeah and I liked that he
could I mean the problem with Johnny
Depp's interpretation was that he seemed
to hate these children he didn't be it's
like you know one of them was like hey
I'm Violet Beauregarde and he was like I
don't care you know what I mean so it's
like he it just seemed like this was a
big trouble for him and he had like all
kind of like you know he didn't want to
interact with anyone whereas Gene Wilder
was very personable when he wanted to
like at the beginning he was like oh hey
everybody and he was very friendly and
you know he's getting him to sign the
contract and he's old so he was like
kind of friendly and happy like happy to
see them he knew their names he talked
to their parents like very flattering
Lee and stuff like that but when they
were in danger he's like oh well then he
was like oh well that [ __ ] happens you
know what I mean so it's like that's
what I think was so brilliant about his
character and why why he's still
remembered yeah when you're that counter
when when dick went when the deaf
interpretation deviated from that
formula it was a mistake it should have
been that that's that character yeah
even if it wasn't that way in the book
that's what sold that yeah that's what
sold that book I think in the book he
was actually not all that sinister okay
you know what I mean I think while that
was Gene Wilder's slight take on it yeah
what he called it right I think he did a
good job of that where he was just kind
of like I mean yes all of the kids like
God you know the same [ __ ] happened to
the kids in the book but I don't think
he was quite
as laissez-faire where he was just like
a good job
the original is very rewatchable too I
could watch that movie every day and be
totally fine with it I love all the kids
are great especially the kid that plays
Charlie Bucket it's it's sad because I
think this was either the only movie he
did or one of a small handful like
apparently I've read somewhere I don't
know if this is true or not but after
this movie he got offered like a five
picture deal and he said now I don't
really want to be an actor like he
became a doctor I think later on I think
he's a doctor he might still be alive
I'm not sure some of the other kids are
not movies shot really well it's got a
really tight edit I love the Edit it's
even-paced through the whole thing it's
an adventure tale yeah and it's got it's
like a rollercoaster ride and it has the
ending that it the ending is perfect and
I love that they spent pretty much half
the movie before you even get to the
factory I loved all the stuff with like
how crazy like the contest is like they
showed like scenes from around the world
like the one woman that it's like they
kidnapped her husband and they're gonna
kill him unless she gives him the crater
Wonka bars and that she's like how long
are they gonna give me to think about
okay I love all those [ __ ] scenes
where it just shows how crazy this thing
is and I love all this stuff with
Charlie where he keeps getting up like
he got a candy bar for his birthday and
then like he you know finds money and
it's like and then like open it but it's
not there so it's just like builds up
builds a no he's not remember I didn't
remember the build up being that long
yeah but when you're a kid you know what
I mean when I was a kid I was patient
school it's coming oh it's coming yeah
oh it's coming you know I mean it and
it's not an easy it's not an easy trip
to get to the damn factory so there by
the time you get there it's almost kind
of like I oh yeah we're here now we're
yeah it was like I really liked that
long and it gave you um all that time to
get invested in Charlie and it's like
every time he buys a candy Barney
doesn't find it you can like feel the
kids discipline it you know what I mean
yeah the whole golden ticket and it's
like how shitty that would be it's like
if you were poor and you can only afford
like one bar and it's like you've hoped
and hoped and then you open and it's not
and it's like finally he gets it and
it's almost kind of like you know you're
like cheering along with the kid because
we waiting the remake doesn't really
have that the remake it's very quick
very quick I get to the factory I like
the golden ticket angles resolved very
quickly and then your ear during the
factory pretty quick yeah you know and
once they get to the factory they they
don't really they don't flush out any of
the kids no really I mean kids not
merely better they don't and is in even
Charlie who's supposed to be the main
character he just kind of like gets
forgotten about you know while Johnny
Depp is walking around Johnny dapping I
think you know what I mean and dip in
the [ __ ] out of play and that's and like
what it's all about him like in his
flashbacks and stuff that humble Lupe's
are more important than the kids in the
movie actually that one hoopuloa that is
all yeah lupus yeah it may seem like
they have a bigger boy that guy's name
is and they just cloned him over and
over and that was another problem I had
and I was watching like some of the
other some other like reviews of this
where people like compared the two or
compared with the book and stuff like
that and I think it was the nostalgia
critic and he said okay now if you were
reading the book and you had never seen
the movies and you saw the word Oompa
Loompa what would you think
and Oompa Loompa looked like it's like I
don't think it would look like the one
in the Tim Burton version where it just
looked like a little person in like an
SN ml fit right you know what I mean
it's like he would look like a little
person with like a orange face and like
green hair and like crazy like pants and
it coated right in the first movie yeah
they would look like what you would
imagine that would look like yeah it was
like a clown yeah it was like a lot more
fantastical yeah um but I don't know I
just feel like the the Tim Burton
version was you know yeah they had all
the CGI you know yeah they did you know
the train squirrels thing which they
actually couldn't do yeah that was cool
scene yeah they couldn't do that from
the book obviously because you know they
didn't have CGI back then and they
couldn't train all that many squirrels I
guess but they geese with the golden
eggs worked just fine you know and Jim
Burton was almost right but the things
that it was lacking uh things that it
made mistakes on was enough for the
whole thing to fall apart if you have
seemed very almost there but it just
wasn't to me it seemed like a lot of
spectacle and it seemed like it was very
try hard and yet it was very lifeless
it's very I would have basically remade
the first movie yeah I mean because
honestly I think that the changes that
they made from the book in the first
movie yeah were the right things to do
like I said they made you know the whole
thing with slugworth and him being like
you know Willy Wonka hiring him and hit
the whole thing with the Everlasting
Gobstopper and him give me it back at
the end like [ __ ] Willy Wonka's like
freak out at the end it's like wrongs
are wrong it was like that was [ __ ]
great yeah I would have just remade that
first movie yeah I mean and at this
point it's like I can't see I don't know
I feel like the original is just so
iconic and has so you know kind of
wormed its way into pop culture that
even to remake it like I can't see Willy
Wonka as anybody other than Gene Wilder
I can't see Veruca Salt as anyone other
than that little girl I just can't see
it and I think Johnny Depp could have
done Gene Wilder's version he could have
and I think he probably could have
topped it wasn't just one took another
direction he just didn't have that that
sarcasm that kind of like he was kind of
malevolent well you saw what he did in
Sweeney Todd I love that one I did too
and like I said I don't have anything
against Tim Burton or Johnny Depp I just
think that was the wrong I would have
just done exact the right I just would
have done I would have made the first
movie I would have read down the first
movie done it better
that's not overdone yeah I mean because
change too much yeah you could do the
special effects you could make you know
the factory seemed bigger you did the
squirrel you could do the squirrels
instead of the geese you know what I
mean you could do [ __ ] that was in the
book I feel like the Tim Burton version
like he tried to put everything that was
in the book he even put this stuff about
Prince Pondicherry and the and the
chocolate [ __ ] which didn't really need
to be in there
it was in the book he was trying to put
everything in there and it just ended up
and then the whole like after the kid
like you know after he they leave the
factory and then like he's gonna go back
and like make peace with his dad's well
why the [ __ ] did that need to be in
there that didn't need to be in there
it's just like slow the whole [ __ ] down
it's like I liked that now they have the
technology to make the factory look you
know the way you would imagine it yeah
but I mean honestly in the 1971 version
I mean I guess because it was the 70s
and
didn't have CGI but it's like to me as
soon as they got into that [ __ ]
Candyland room like in the beginning I
was like wow it was like super amazing
yeah you know what I mean and I should
note that a lot of that candy and there
was actually edible yeah and that 71 the
ending of the 71 version was perfect you
know it I just wanted the movie is what
people wanted that's what sold that damn
book yeah so I just went over to just
remake that movie yeah I mean it was
done Matt any better
maybe Burton as it as you know as a
director he's like well that's easy I
don't want to do that you know I
couldn't understand that you know he
wanted to put his own signature on it
right that's fair back to the book but
that's not what that's not what the
audience wanted I mean the whole thing
it's like that's what kind of pissed me
off and I think it was like this in the
book too I mean all this [ __ ] about you
know Willy Wonka's backstory that wasn't
in the book that was something that Tim
Burton put in there cuz I guess he's got
daddy issues that he needs to sort out
or something but it's like well it seems
like a lot of his movies have that have
that yeah so that wasn't in the book and
I don't know why it had to be in there
cuz like I said demystifying Willy Wonka
was not a good idea just like
demystifying the imple who's never a
good idea to demystify oh I shouldn't
know about him the better right because
the like they said in the original you
didn't know where did he come from what
it's like why is this we simply
mysterious and that was like way better
because you never knew what was gonna
happen you didn't know he was gonna do
but it's like that was one thing that
they did like at the end like he gives
the kid the factory and then the kid
says oh my family can't come so [ __ ] you
I don't want a hat I don't want to do
that because like I said the kid was
like saintly and it was like kind of
annoying because no kid would be like
that every kid would be like okay I came
into my own I can have candy no yes
it's like my fan yeah so it's like and
then like they had to go through and
resolve the daddy issues and then he's
like okay well my family's not so bad
after all so now all the family can move
in and [ __ ] like that I mean where you
had to put like the end of the original
the 1971 you know we're pretty much
Willy Wonka's like you know you're such
a great kid and like you passed the test
and you know I can't you know I'm I
can't run the factory forever and you're
like the best kid I found so he just
immediately said do you want the factory
and he said can i my family move in and
he's like yeah so there was that was the
end and he's like yeah
happy ending yeah that's fantastic yeah
you know I mean it's like just they
prolonged the [ __ ] too much amber that's
the way kids see reality anyway and then
anything a kid would like oh I'm good
enough okay it's mine now and you can
have it all you can have all the candy
all your family can come you can have
the flying elevator you can eat all of
it right and it's like so I think that
was like way better and it was tied up
much quicker it was just kind of like
they didn't have like all this like
needless [ __ ] at the end where it's just
like oh the kid was too good to like too
too holy to like take the [ __ ] on unless
his family could go just like that just
seemed like kind of I don't know it just
seemed unnecessary like I said the kid
in the first one I mean I related to
that kid you seemed like a real kid
they could have changed it to where that
was the test like no I can't leave my
family behind okay you got it that okay
you win yeah yeah yeah but it's like no
they had this whole thing about Willy
Wonka and it's like he had daddy issues
and it's like they had those had to be
resolved it focused too much on him and
that's what I mean it's like I feel like
it's funny that I mean Roald Dahl has
passed away obviously and they weren't
allowed to like make charlie in the
great glass elevator because he didn't
like the original movie all that much
and he said okay well you got to wait
till after I'm dead like to make another
[ __ ] movie of this so they did that
um and it's ironic that he thought the
original movie focused too much on Willy
Wonka not enough on Charlie whereas the
Tim Burton version is pretty much all
about Willy Wonka I mean they kind of
forget about Charlie especially after
they get to the I don't even think he
has that many lines like after they get
to this none of the kids do like after
they get to the factory it's all about
the spectacle and Willy Wonka's
weirdness and it's just it just didn't
work for me it's like I really like I
said I loved him Burton I love you know
Johnny Depp but that it just felt like
cringy it was really cringey
yeah Wonka's weirdness wasn't wasn't
compelling either it was just like not
that weird
it was just cringe II like he said yeah
it wasn't yeah it wasn't weird it wasn't
like dangerous like Gene Wilder's won
and like kind of like fascinating it was
just kind of like ooh get away from me
creep it's like some weirdo that would
sit next to me on the bus you know what
I mean it was like that where I just
wanted to get away you
it's like that's what he gave me a
Michael Jackson vibe and it's like I
just wanted to get the [ __ ] away from
him whereas Gene Wilder's character it's
like even though you thought he might be
slightly crazy but he was yeah you kind
of wanted to hang out with that guy
because you didn't know what was gonna
happen he seemed super cool he also
seemed more like an adult that could
actually run a Chocolate Factory
whereas Johnny Depp's character kind of
seemed like a magician or a child in a
man's body that wouldn't be able to run
a successful Chocolate Factory so I
didn't really buy it there everybody in
the Tim Burton version just seemed like
a caricature and not like a real person
yeah where's everybody in the original
movies it seemed a lot more grounded in
reality and everyone seemed like a real
person even though it did have kind of
like a fantastical or fantasy like a
fairy tale type of atmosphere and I say
it's funny because I grew up as many
times as I've seen this [ __ ] movie the
whole time I grew up I thought it was
shot in the UK just from the you know
outside the street it's not it's Munich
it's Germany and Ivar look like British
cars yeah and even that well they sell
the same ones around Europe and stuff
like that even that the factory the that
they use for walk in fact I was a real
factory it was the Munich Gas Works so
they wanted to use Munich because one it
was way cheaper to film over there than
it was in the US but to because they
wanted it to not be immediately
recognizable to American audiences but
it's like I was always confused because
I'm like Charlie's at school and like
his set his teachers British and then
like some of the other kids like peruca
and stuff were British but then there's
like American kids and but then there's
America it wasn't happening over the
whole world so yeah it was kind of
supposed to be like you weren't really
supposed to know where it was taking
place cuz it was supposed to be like a
fantastical yellow so everybody lives in
Munich you know you you live in like
fairytale land alright so we probably
gone on about this long enough but yeah
like I said I love this movie um both
versions are on Netflix if you want to
compare the two I'm actually kind of
pissed off that I watched the Tim Burton
one consensus just maybe he's kind of
sad and it made me want to watch the
original one again even though I watched
it a couple nights ago but yeah it was
that bad um I just I don't know maybe it
made me angry and it's just like
if if they had had somebody else play it
like you know because they were actually
going
get like John Cleese or somebody like
that I think that would have been a lot
better yeah but it's just I just didn't
like Johnny Depp in it or at least I
didn't like his take on it
I know his take but yeah I mean he could
have done Wilders version but they
didn't yeah seriously if you've never
seen the 1971 a rose you definitely
definitely have to see that I mean Gene
Wilder is [ __ ] amazing in it all the
kids are great in it it's just the songs
are great you know they still remember
them even though at the time it seemed
like it seemed like people said oh the
songs weren't that memorable and like
fish shows what you know
everybody still remembers that I heard
just heard pure imagination in a [ __ ]
ad for Apple or something like that that
yeah I can't believe that song was not
in the remake of that movie I mean what
the hell are they doing I don't know
maybe they they probably couldn't get
the rights to it but they wanted to do a
whole thing yeah but seriously check it
out they're both on Netflix like I said
I don't recommend the new one but the
original is a classic and if you haven't
seen it you really need to rectify that
situation right now